In 1315, Scotland’s King Robert the Bruce
decided to lay siege
to England's Carlisle Castle.
Robert expected a swift victory,
but his men arrived to find
a relentless downpour.
Struggling against muck and mud,
they tried to fill the moat
with corn husks
only for the husks to float away.
Then Robert ordered the construction
of a massive siege tower,
but the English responded
with wooden scaffolds
that heightened the castle walls.
Their final push to scale those walls
ended with English arrows raining down
on the sodden Scots.
At a time when sieges could last
months or even years,
Robert retreated after just 11 days.
This siege is a prime example
of how medieval European castles
could stand firm against enemy onslaughts.
But castles weren’t just
for passive defense;
they were symbols of power,
private residences,
and hubs of governance intended
to impress and intimidate.
In fact, they were just as likely
to be used for offensive military tactics.
Castles regularly served
as bases for launching attacks
and as a way to control local populations
with promises of shelter
or threats of violence.
While citadels and fortified palaces could
be found as early as the 8th century BCE,
European castles as we think of them
started appearing in large numbers
in the late 9th century CE.
At this time, the ruling
Carolingian Empire was breaking down.
And as the monarch’s control
over his 1 million square kilometer
realm disintegrated,
nobles began building castles
to solidify their regional power.
These early wooden castles
followed the motte and bailey design,
featuring a central tower
built atop a steep mound
with a walled yard at the base.
But over the following centuries,
as castles became centers
of social, cultural, military,
and political life,
their designs grew more varied
and complex.
By the 12th century, many wooden motte
and baileys had been rebuilt with stone,
increasing their defense and longevity.
Subsequent castles built in stone
from the start
used curtain walls and gatehouses
to enclose the castle yard.
And their walls and towers were often
coated in a layer of protective limewash,
covering their stony grey
with a range of colorful tones.
Alongside their scale,
visual beauty was a way
for castles to project power.
Castle Caernarfon in northern Wales
was built with bands of
different colored stone.
And Crusader armies building castles
in the Middle East
often incorporated elements of intricate
Islamic and Byzantine architecture.
But as European castles
became more widespread,
so did technologies to defeat them.
Fire had long threatened
wooden motte and baileys,
and while their stone counterparts
were more resistant,
their underlying wooden structure
was still vulnerable to arson.
Battering rams cracked castle doors,
siege towers and mining operations
thwarted castle walls,
and trebuchets launching stones
up to 130 kilograms
endangered entire structures.
Rectangular castle towers
were especially vulnerable
since their square corners
had fewer load bearing stones.
Fortunately, when the Crusaders
returned to Europe from the Middle East,
they brought home
architectural innovations,
including the design
for concentric castles.
Featuring numerous rings of
defensive walls around a central tower,
this approach created a circular fortress
with multiple layers of siege security.
From the 13th century onward,
this design reigned supreme,
even standing up to the small cannons
that had begun spreading across Europe.
But by the 15th century,
the high towers that once rained
arrows on attackers
became easy targets
for powerful new cannons.
While castle builders adapted
by making squatter structures
with walls up to three meters thick,
this kind of construction
was prohibitively expensive.
By the early 16th century,
most local nobles couldn’t keep
up with the costs,
and became reliant
on strong centralized rulers
who could afford to support modern
defenses and large standing armies.
This financial and political pressure,
alongside advances in gunpowder weapons,
put an end to castles’ military dominance.
Most of these fortresses
were converted to residences,
administrative centers, or prisons,
and today many still serve as tourist
attractions and private estates.
But while they no longer protect
their inhabitants from sieging armies,
they still project the grandeur
and authority
that made medieval castles
so effective for centuries.